I didn't think we could even get you
come on what could we know each other
yeah I consider you a bud do you not is
that not nice not even a putt though you
know what I said to you yeah thank you
and I went to Nam together sure yeah
like you know like when you go see
somebody from Nam for a while huh huh
right well I mean miss saigon yeah yeah
I know you do have ever been them Nami
in a war situation not nice I have a lot
of Canadian friends who vacation there
now that's what it's become you can even
my wife is yeah they're great
you people don't know this and if you do
you don't but let me tell you learn and
unlearn okay is that when I my first
show was AB some people a lot of people
know was MADtv and I tested to get on
the show with Karen was young I riders
to us yeah Oh their lives which one
would we want [ __ ] or regular white yeah
I'm sure that's not what they say said
in the road were you 19 Dan how old are
you 30 no we hung out cuz we met they
brought us in for rehearsals to and we
met there we went to Hollywood Center
studios and did that hold like studio
session thing yeah it was either you or
Hanlon no no it was not like a we tested
we auditioned rehearsed and then tested
together we played video games
afterwards right at that lot they did
Fox at the time they had like two or
three like up right video you know yeah
they want to be about James yeah yeah
and we just played in the lobby after
testing you know and then saw Nicole in
the parking lot yeah and she was like
you guys both the grade don't worry guys
and then I got called that day how do
you do
yeah so but I didn't see you again until
virgin megastore do you remember that no
I ran into you but like
week maybe two later at Virgin Megastore
at Crescent Heights and sunset and I
didn't know if you got it and I was like
hey yeah oh you didn't even alright and
you're like and I was like hey I got it
oh wow and I was like oh and then the
first thing you said is have you used it
to get laid yet and I said no yeah we
yeah I think I probably my voice crash
oh my god some people so perfect this
guy yeah Wow oh my god you'll bust
[ __ ] killed me just now bro don't
ever do that again
kidding no you're so good and then so
there was no internet by that back then
you know didn't research Google like
yeah yeah yeah and and and the first
thing I read was TV Guide they'd like
announced it in TV Guide and it was like
like a hard meeting a hard copy exactly
yeah I get 3/4 rectangle did they have
the internet I don't remember they did
it was like that yeah dial-up oh that's
something out of there and then uh
talking amanda Bynes at the time that is
true yeah huh but this is uh you don't
talk to her anymore
I had no no she we were dating a little
over two years and then she wisely broke
up with me
Wow we were very young as you know but
that she did that destroy your news I
was very sad very sad really
yeah yeah oh my god very very since I
remember her because she would show up
to LA he came and would hang and hang
out and stopped and I'd be like oh she's
so eight in fact every time I would run
into her after that just so sweet she's
just the nicest yeah charming and
imagine them at that age her show yeah I
did it was sort of my first job out of
high school was like I did like ended up
doing seven episodes of her show
yeah I'm so good yeah it's fun thanks
man
it's a testament I'm standing yeah look
at this thing it's a testament to your
talent that you're able to go from
Nickelodeon mm-hmm and also do to sketch
shows the only two really that was on at
the time really you know it really is a
it's it's amazing thanks buddy how do
you feel it was nice
good a color on you go I'm the [ __ ] or
no no I would never do I would I look
and I go okay I go that's that's pretty
cool that's yeah impressive so we did a
year and it was it wasn't but we did
like a like 13 right because I hired for
four and then and they and you me and
Catherine Catherine got tired a little
bit later than us
Fiore if you're a try and and and it was
like in the first the first 13 episodes
we would overlap so you and I all needed
like two episodes together and then you
do it too with Catherine and then you do
too by your side it was so weird yeah it
was so weird and also it was like almost
like they were you know you you think
that you were you're inviting to this
family and then you know because there's
guys that have been on this show for a
very long time and it doesn't feel warm
sure you know that some people are like
no yeah like hi you go good morning they
go no yeah okay for sure and then
there's some people are gay ka Will
Sasso oh the best is the best here's a
guy who is warm Canadian Canadian and
and in you know my opinion I'm sure I'm
biased now liking him so but the
funniest - oh yeah what are the funniest
yeah yeah in fact of one where was I was
there and like I think a month in he was
like it's kind of mouse is a BBQ and
like that kind of thing without that
gesture yeah I might have not survived
totally yeah
right there was there like I can count
on one hand
the people who went out of their way
Mike Hitchcock was one from all he's the
best the best yeah he really looked out
for me when I sold the show after I yeah
Jennifer Joyce was very kind one of the
best Jewish yeah Scott King yeah I mean
all those guys even like Lauren
Dombrowski was Maya yeah yeah same same
I loved Lauren too but uh so then you
did 13 in the nose at I did 13 and they
asked me back but wanted to ask me back
for 17 of 22 they're like trying to
renegotiate cuz you know if you got what
it was supposed to be the full 22 or
whatever and my reps at the time were
like you don't need it forget them
that's insulting and I listened to them
was that regretable or no probably not
at the time it was tough yeah cuz even
17 is like a serious salary for a 20
year old yeah I've left college to do
the show and couldn't really get back in
so like my parents were a little bit
like what the [ __ ] are you saying
no to work yeah long term it worked out
good amazing yeah because when you left
then they brought Mike and Josh Meyers
right and that's where my pain started
because these two kids like if you don't
know Josh is Seth Meyers his younger
brother Ike Barinholtz is on the Mindy
project and on every everything right
now
and they work together they were a duo
the audition together right yeah you're
so smart you know everything about that
stuff and they and the writers knew them
to rise well right sure and I was a
stand-up and I didn't know how to do it
yet I still might not know how it's
still mine I could even you know they
say that the old term fake it to you
makeup yeah yeah do that
well I mean like we attempted a couple
of time I remember us trying to like
write a snowboard sketch please tell me
how that way
well also because we didn't have real
dressing rooms we were in a trailer
outside of the building dry we're in
like that were the new kids yeah yeah
everybody else had like DS and against a
so it was the year that the tenacious d
album came out so I would go into his
dressing room and he'd play the songs
and we'd sing him again oh wow yeah he's
the back yes and that was um that was
the year where my first sketch was I
played Jackie Chan of course absolutely
played Chris Tucker and Will Sasso was
Lance Bass and we were on see what
happens
and I remember lives on the cover of
peeple right now oh really I feel like
those amazing yeah that would be amazing
they should do that movie or whatever
but oh good so they had me on they had
me in early
I was the earliest guy for the call
sheet but I was the last sketch this is
about you know the kinetic with the
prosthetic nose yes this is back in the
day when otherwise it wouldn't have
looked like Jackie Chan was that a
racial dig no I'm just saying I had a
killer channel but they had me in early
but that I was the last sketch wouldn't
like if I had to do it now I'm the last
I'm gonna come in last right but they
could just like put me in at five of the
mornings only have me sit there all day
you know man but anyway you get the Pat
you get the the print out the email so
obviously there's internet the night
before of the list and you'd like I
would go through and like which parts
I'm gonna read and the stress of all my
like those are the yeah were they the
worst they were tricky they were tricky
in what way because you didn't get him
emailed they would drop it off at your
house that's right right by mail right
somebody would literally drive here yes
Hackett's were like this stage yeah they
would read like 45 sketches and it would
pick six and you sit at like a Last
Supper table with all the cast right so
you're all like side by side with every
but you can't really you actor relate
and it's just all the producers and
writers across from network across from
me did you get fired at these table
reads like if you don't think so
terribly me not in my time they're not
in my experience
well I mean not on our show but you've
heard of it and our pilots pilots
frequently yeah yeah yeah but here's the
problem all right so you're there's
forty three sketches that you get but
you might be in for yeah yeah right
and if the only they pick six out of 43
that would mean nothing
mmm-hmm and I remember that's what was
hard for me is I would go to the thing
your name's not and I would be Japanese
businessman number one I have no line oh
I'm a [ __ ] tree not a tree not being
a [ __ ] tree yeah and it had nothing
to do with the sketch it was like I
don't know what else to do with them
alright yeah we got to put a minute you
know and I remember I just didn't know
how to do it and I remember like even
just stuttering were you know what they
did to meet Aaron when you left
özkan here they made a there was a tape
passed around to all the riders of all
my flub lines and I was like a joke real
kind of a thing they were passing around
for a year it was like not you know
afraid was like one of those things like
you know how you like we'd watch youtube
videos of like a lady slipping on grapes
and breaking her back
yeah but that was not me and yeah when I
find that I saw the tape and it said
Bobby and I don't know whatever Bobby's
a [ __ ] idiot or whatever on the pan
like what is that no well that's every
scene you do right God and I was just
like you guys made that I think super
funny the source was it's tricky because
there's also such power and I found this
true at SNL as well that the writers
have this weird power where they are
determining the material for the most
parts and with no vocal risk right like
no no no perceptible risk because you
know 40 sketches and you can barely
remember but if you're the one who has
to read it in front of all of your peers
yeah it's a real unfair pressure and I'm
sure like that was put together sort of
like you know ha ha ha comedy people
rising and roasted but but without the
empathy of like what you have to go to
yeah every week yourself out asking
everybody on the show out to the dance
basically yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]